now officials in Iran have handed down
the death sentence to five people
charged with a killing of a member of
these Security Forces it's the latest in
a series of harsh sentences for
anti-government protesters Iran's rulers
are facing their biggest challenge in
decades after the death in police
custody of a young woman in September
that sparked demonstrations calling for
regime change today marks day three of a
nationwide strike shopkeepers and truck
drivers have stopped work in solidarity
with the movement
and gusunia is the director of the
Strategic litigation project at the
global Affairs Think Tank the Atlantic
Council she works on prevention and
accountability efforts for human rights
violations thanks so much for joining us
gisu I know that you've been watching
these protests closely since they began
back in September protesters are pushing
for change but is there any reason to
believe that the regime will allow any
real change
I think the protesters have been very
clear about what it is that they want
and they want a full-scale change of the
system
um what we see right now with these
execution sentences and these very
Draconian punishments and the torture of
um thousands of prisoners who are being
detained is a regime that is very
worried about their future prospects
um and that's why we see this kind of
harsh clamp down
um I'm here in New York this week to
meet with UN member states about the
Islamic republics of Iran's multilateral
engagement at the UN and and they're
very concerned about where things stand
you've talked about you've mentioned the
the torture the the harsh Crackdown
we're hearing reports of of massive
arrests people being sentenced to death
is it possible for you and others in
your line of work to track and record uh
rights violations in Iran
yeah this is a question that comes up a
lot because obviously a lot of us are
not given access to alleged crime scenes
in country were we to go and do field
research
um we ourselves would be jailed
um and presumably not given access
however there's a lot of Open Source
information that comes out of the
country in the form of videos photos
that are disseminated on social media
and in chat groups and also through
virtual testimonies so this question
came up with the recent establishment of
a fact-finding mission in Geneva by the
Human Rights Council and there were
questions about how one could actually
collect evidence if one does not have
access to the country and and the
authorities don't consent to that but in
this day and age there are actually a
lot of ways that we can collect preserve
and analyze evidence that don't involve
access to a crime scene
do you think that the protest movement
has enough momentum to continue despite
the the violence the government
Crackdown that you've talked about
well the thing that's very different
about the speed of protest which is now
being called A revolution is that for
example in November 2019 when there were
Nationwide anti-government protests
um those were quickly quelled because
um more than you know of reports of 1500
to even more people were killed in the
space of a few days by the state and
then people didn't come out on the
street again here we see that despite
all the reports despite the fact that
there's more than 18 000 protesters in
jail despite the handing down of
execution sentences the reports of
sexual assault and torture and enforced
disappearance the youth and many others
are still coming to the streets and now
it's gotten to the point where Workers
are striking so I think whatever has
happened here cannot be peddled back and
the Iranian authorities should be taking
this very very seriously a gisu near
human rights lawyer thank you so much
for taking the time to speak with us
today
I'm now joined by Siva Shakib she's an
Iranian German filmmaker and writer now
what do you hear from Iran today are
many people there supporting this
Nationwide strike
yes absolutely
um it's so many people and so many
messages that I could fill the whole day
lining up the messages that I'm getting
and the phone calls that I'm getting the
um
interviews I do with people
now the five people have been sentenced
to death for allegedly killing a member
of the passage a paramilitary group
affiliated with the country's
revolutionary guard what effects do you
think do harsh verdicts like this have
on the protests
it'll just ignite them one more time and
now we are beginning to see a very soft
um opposition also from very close uh
people who are very close to the regime
for instance
the highest person in in the Islamic
Republic
his sister has denounced there is no
other word I can think of now her
brother and she says he does not hear
the voice of people that's a big thing
your own sister
um saying that you don't hear the voice
of people in your country
now just a few days ago Iranian
officials announced they would abolish
the country's so-called morality police
is that just a cosmetic change or is it
a sign that the regime might be willing
to allow change
it doesn't matter anymore whether they
keep it or have it or or
whatever they want to do
we don't accept any more small changes
or changes any kind of changes we want
this regime to go and that's it and it's
basically also no news because the
demand in the streets of Iran in all
cities that Harmony has to go that
Islamic Republic has to go have been
loud since weeks and weeks so it's just
a small trial of Islamic Republic to
maybe convince a handful of people but
they don't nobody nobody believes them
anything and nobody would say okay maybe
now that you want to abolish the
morality police okay you can stay no
this is not going to happen
now many people and governments across
Europe and in the US indeed are showing
solidarity with the protesters in Iran
is that enough or can something more be
done from outside to support women's
rights in Iran
well first of all until this regime is
in place until the Israel Islamic
Republic is in place we have to try
everything from outside to help the
people of Iran to continue their
Revolution and to end the Islamic
Republic so far a lot of things have
been achieved outside Iran 8 million
Iranians outside the country are not
outside the country just because they
like living somewhere else but most of
us we are outside the country because we
wouldn't be able to live inside the
country because our lives are threatened
and we have tried a lot we have achieved
a lot but of course there has to be done
more and one of the things that we have
been asking for and that we are fighting
for is close all embassies of the
Islamic Republic and sent home all the
employees the diplomats the
um ambassadors and people who are close
to the Islamic Republic or put them in
prison now that we have the United
Nations uh truth finding commission
um we have certain rights we can put
them also in in in in prison or take
them to court
thank you very much
thank you thank you for being the voice
giving us a voice in you uh the people
of Iran